الكارثه التي تتصدر كحدثا اول عالميا
لصعوبه وقسوه المشاهد التي تمخضت عنها
مشاهدوا انقاذ ورفع انقاض ولحظات قليله من
الفرح بانتشالي احياء من تحت الركام بعد
خمسه ايام من وقوع الزلزال فاكثر من مئه
ساعه تلاشى بعدها الامل شيئا فشيئا للوصول
الى نجي خاصه في ظل البرد القارس الشديد
عدد القتلى ارتفع الى نحو 24 الف شخص في
تركيا وبحسب الرئيس التركي اردوغان تجاوز
عدد القتلى
19.88 شخصا واكثر من سبعه وسبعين الف مصاب
اما في سوريا اعلن المرصد السوري ان حصيله
القتلى وصلت الى
4500 وهي مرشحه للوصول الى سته الاف في
مناطق اعلنت اليوم منكوبه حلب اللاذقيه
ادلب الشمال السوريه يضع الماساه فوق
ماساه حجم الكارثه فيه يفوق قدره الجميع
بحسب منظمه الصحه العالميه ففي هذه البقعه
من الخريطه السوريه يسكن او كان يسكن اكثر
من اربعه ملايين اكثر من 70% منهم يعيشون
على مساعدات امميه بالاساس كانت مناشداتهم
بناء بيوت لهم اصبحت احلامهم بعد السلسال
خيمه